مع الفجر ، وانتهت أعنف
ليالي قصف ميخائيل حتى الآن
ولكن ليس للخوف الذي يجلبه
في أعقاب حرائق مباشرة
لإخماد الوفيات الوحيدة في هذا
القصر السكني المليونير
رجل الأعمال أليكسي فاراتوريكسكي
وزوجته المتسابقة كانوا يحتمون في
الطابق السفلي  عندما تعرض المنزل لضربة مباشرة
لجيراننا ما زلنا في حالة صدمة ، لا نعرف
ماذا نفعل
نحن نكره روسيا في
الواقع
،
إنه أمر لا يصدق أنه يمكن في
لحظة واحدة تدمير كل شيء عاشه ماكسيم
هنا منذ 20 عامًا تقريبًا ولكن ربما
لا أفعل أكثر من ذلك
.  لا أريد البقاء هنا الآن ،
تعطيك هذه الحفرة هنا
فكرة عن حجم الانفجار الذي نتج عن الحطام
المتناثر هنا ، كما أصابت نوافذ
المبنى
المباني الأخرى الموجودة هنا أيضًا
بأولئك الذين لديهم روابط عسكرية خارج
حدود كاميراتنا
المتعاطفون الروس القلقون تجاهي ،
أنا متأكد من أن لديهم
جواسيس يتجولون في المدينة
ويقولون كما لو
رأيت عدد الآلات أو الأشخاص
العسكريين  أرسلوا هذه المعلومات والهجمات الروسية
هناك وتعتقد أن هؤلاء
المخربين ربما ساعدوا في
الهجمات الليلة الماضية ،
أنا متأكد من أنهم ساعدوا في
غضون ساعات في العودة إلى ما
يمر كمتقاعدين عاديين وآخرين
في طابور لشرب مياه المدينة
النظيفة  لقد دمرت الإمدادات منذ أشهر
، وضربونا وضربونا بشدة من
الساعة الواحدة صباحًا حتى الصباح ، تخبرنا فالنتينا
أننا خائفون من أننا نريد المغادرة ، لكن
هكذا هي الحياة بالنسبة لنا الآن
حيث تم قصف القصر وأصبح السكان
أكثر ثراءً في حي آخر
لرجل الأعمال المتوفى.  أنا لا يستطيع تحمل
الأمر بعد الآن أنه سيغادر البرازيل
ليس واضحًا ما إذا كان رجل الأعمال
البارز أليكسي فاراتورسكي كان هدفًا مقصودًا
للرئيس زيلينسكي جعله بطلاً
وفاته وتيرة الإيقاع هنا
تقشعر لها الأبدان المزاج المرن لهذه المدينة
نيك روبرسون CNN  ميخائيلا أوكرانيا